we are following the story of a cruise
ship where 21 passengers and crew
members got the coronavirus many Grand
Princess passengers are waking up at US
military bases this morning after the
ship docked in Oakland California
the critically-ill are now in care our
league national correspondent David beg
no spoke to one of the passengers with a
uniquely harrowing story David what did
she tell you Michelle this is the story
of Carrie coal stove her family reached
out to me over the weekend and said
David she's a stage 4 cancer patient
we've got to get her off that ship what
can be done so I reached out to her
United States Senator he said he was
involved Kerry was told the vice
president was aware of her condition and
they were trying to get her off and then
the ship docked doctors had cleared Cole
stowed to go on the Grand Princess
cruise to take a break from her
treatments but it is not the experience
she expected she actually sent me this
picture last night of her and her
husband Paul wearing masks they were
sitting on a bus waiting to go they
waited for three hours before the bus
finally left and headed to Travis Air
Force Base which is about an hour away
she told me she was in horrific back
pain because of the cancer that has
spread to her spine she says doctors
gave her radiation and pain medication
before she left with the idea that she
would get home Carrie has a chemo
appointment scheduled for today in
Minnesota but she is not going to make
that I actually text her a short time
ago it's about 5:00 in the morning in
California she has not not yet responded
she does not have a fever
she has no symptoms of the corona virus
but she's going to need to be
quarantined for two weeks so she's
trying to figure out where can I go
can I get chemo can I do it while I'm
quarantined can I get back to North
Dakota and guys as I send it back to you
know she said look David my case is no
more important than somebody else's but
I do have a weakened immune system and I
need someone to check me out and see if
we can get me home yes that's a
harrowing story indeed and you know I'm
sure one of many as people have
competing medical ailments and things
that they have to take take a look at
right right David thank you very much